I had so many girls in the show tell me
that lizzo is like above a five which is
just like crazy
everyone's scale is different at the end
of the day what your five is yeah
I think I think objectively like if
you're 300 pounds you're below a five
that's your opinion though that's your
opinion I mean that's your opinion but
it's based off of reality which women
don't like to live in because even this
is like not reality and you know it on
some level because you know if you walk
into a bar with lizzo you guys are all
going to get more attention than lizzo
like do you know not necessarily like if
you're looking for exceptions it's not
the rule like you could take you could
take you could take dating app data
where we like let's like put your
profile on Liz's profile who's gonna get
more attention it's gonna be you we
could go into a modeling a modeling
agency and say who are they going to
sign you or lizzo in general unless you
do that Victoria's Secret to like you
know the new body positivity type [ __ ] I
know again again exceptions but whenever
you go anywhere where there's like an
objective standard of beauty where like
people are finding this the most
attractive General your you guys are all
prettier than lizzo and that's not
that's what my question is and I think
yeah you make some again interesting
points around like it's really helpful
to see that like I I don't know if you
guys always see like the stats that come
out from certain dating apps and if I'm
allowed to say certain names but they
they produce these stuff right like who
comes out as the most desirable woman my
question would be and modeling agencies
and modeling agencies yeah
um by whose beauty standards I was just
gonna say that I mean I would say like
collectively society as a whole so if
you survey if you survey if you survey
men and women as well and you if you
survey men and women as a whole in
general in most Societies in London they
put in most and Moses and most societies
throughout the world everywhere I
guaranteed like just like just based out
wait let me let me finish in most
societies throughout the world
everywhere if we put a picture of you
guys in a picture of lizzo if you ask
most guys and most girls they would find
you more attractive in West Africa and
except yeah they always this is what
this is what girls do like so I've been
doing in this couple months not you
personally but like like this is what
they'll do they'll bring up the one
exception and that one Society in in
West Africa you're right there's one
Society in West Africa where that is the
exception but everywhere else that is
the rule I think my social
bureau-centric way of Young Beauty look
at the size of Africa let's look at the
size of you I won't even do all that I
won't even do all that I think what we
can also look at is just Beauty standard
shift right like I was 10 years ago
having a like a fat ass was like okay
you but nowadays it's like if you don't
have a fat ass you're not attracted
exactly so that stays a while wait talk
talk and you're talking sorry it stays a
while when there's a standard set so
um let's say 10 years ago being a
supermodel model Finn was in fashion it
will stay there for a little bit then
they'll come another Trend yeah it's not
like it just changes but but the point
I'm making is that the issue that I'm
having is and I agree with you it's
weird I didn't think I was going to
disagree with you as much as I'm doing
today but
um when it comes down to that number of
like or you're a five and below it's
like okay
10 years ago if I had a fat accident I'm
at five and below but I didn't say 10
years ago I said today what I'm just
saying like it shifts so for you to say
like oh like I I'm not gonna comment on
lizzo but for you to say that so
definitively that if you're over this
you're that I think that's what people
have a hard time dealing with and on top
of that it's like we connect that what's
that five mean okay do you think do you
think in most of human history okay one
there probably wasn't even women over
300 pounds and most of human history but
since since the development of like
obesity has obesity ever been desired by
and large by Ben by and large I I can't
call it I don't know hey come on just
with your common sense just with your
common sense I mean with my common sense
I want to say no but that's okay that's
right I don't know what them just by and
large I just think personally speaking
in London in terms of 2022 now what is
considered like a 10 is very different
like we said it was five years ago and
I'm not gonna lie being thick which is
um thick comes in all different shapes
and sizes it can go from somebody that
is let's say a size 12 but she's got
really thick thighs or a big bum or
something someone that's a size 18. it
is different I would say I don't
personally agree to say someone that's
over 300 pounds would then be considered
below a five I I don't personally agree
with that and I think a lot of I'm gonna
say especially in London specifically I
don't think a lot of people are going to
sit there and say that I mean I mean I
think sometimes like you have a warped
world view because
um like the society is made for women so
like 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions are made
um by women and so you see the whole
media is tailored towards women so when
you see women in the media it's like
pretty much just to cater to women but
the thing is like the majority of the
most desired women if if they're thicker
they have a small waist it's always been
The Hourglass but you get some women
that could be over 300 pounds and have a
small waste that happens
you can see some girls that are maybe
let's say it's pretty tall I know what a
size 18.
I'm in the top top one percent of high
if I was 300 no no you're right but I've
been pleasantly surprised like sometimes
you'll ask a girl or
yeah and we would weigh more than you
would expect exactly but but I'm saying
it's 300 no 300's pushing it 300 is
definitely pushing because yeah I don't
know what the ranger looks like on a guy
let alone no wrong but I mean I always
like to count a question to ask all the
ladies in the room generally speaking
would you be more attracted to a man
that's over six foot or around that
region there in comparison to someone
let's say my height five foot seven
with with a good personality naturally
with your instincts what do you feel
you're selling yourself well I love it
Hey listen I will keep it real I feel
like we should be diplomatic I feel like
you haven't spoken that much well
personally I've never been interested in
height like it doesn't bother me whether
they're the same height as me taller
shorter whatever like I am much more of
an emotional person than I am sort of
that side of things that's not what I
initially go for it's like that
connection with the person I don't care
whether they're taller than me or not or
whether they've got you know a dad board
or a six-pack like that aesthetic side
of it isn't important obviously you've
got to have an attraction somebody to
want to be with them but I don't think I
would necessarily go for somebody who's
got those Norms if they do they do but
that's not what I intentionally look for
three inches shorter than you yes yeah
who said no me okay at least you're
honest I think no I haven't I'm being
better and I would date somebody who's
the same height as me but personally I
would just feel like um you see if I
wear heels I understand like there is
that element but I would overall like to
be with a man that's at least the same
height as me or taller because it just
makes me feel like I don't know if I
think it's more masculine I'm just
attracted to that
um
personally
um and I've had like the best connection
with someone and you honestly were like
this person is my soul mate like I I
have I can get on with them better than
anyone else and I generally want to you
know spend the rest of my life with them
whatever but then you go all right
everybody there's a few he's a few
inches shorter than me I'm just being
realistic because you see I'm I'm not
necessarily like a man like a visual
creature but you know the first thing
you look at is actually looks so even if
let's say you're not my usual type or
there is something about you that's you
know like oh you're not my perfect type
I feel like there needs to be that sort
of attraction and if there's no
attraction between me and that person I
would just see them more as a friend per
se and that's just me personally no I do
agree with you in that sense like in
terms of your original question would I
date a guy that's your high or not the
same height as me yes I would if someone
was three inches shorter than me no I
wouldn't mainly because I